世の  世の中だと普通この
はっきりしない問題がありますってのは
それは 善と悪という問題なんですね
善ってなんですか 悪ってなんですかっていうこと
これまあ 人の考え方によっても変わっちゃうしね
ある人がいいというものは
ある人が別に まあいいとは言わない
悪いと言うしね ですからまあ
人によっても 善悪の考え方っていうのは変わっちゃう
国によっても変わるし
同じ国にしたっても まあそのその人はみんな同じこと
善と悪ことを思ってるわけじゃないんですね
それでまあ 年によっても変わっちゃうんですね
で 小さい時 善と悪と思っているものと
大きくなってから 大人になってから善と悪と思っているものはまた違うんですね
それだけじゃなくて この
時代によっても変わるんですよ
で 昔悪いと思ったものは今はいいと言っちゃうし
昔いいと言ったものは今は悪いと言っちゃうし
うん やっぱり普段の あの
善悪観というのは まあそういうもので
まあはっきりしない だから五十年
五十年じゃないね まあ五十八年前
行って人殺すことは日本でいいということになってましたしね
まあそれで まあ今は戦争することはもう悪いと
言ってるし 前はそれが正しいと
それが素晴らしい行為であると
言ってます だから東京の人々は
まあいいことをしようと
思っていて死んでしまっちゃったんですね
だから東京の人々いいことをしたんですけど
今の人々いいことをしてるんですかね
わからないんですね で
うん で 今は戦争はいいと言ってるんだけど
あと何年間経ったところで何言うかわからないしね
ですから この世の中っていうのはそうやって
一つのことにたっても
まあ価値観というのはね
善悪っていうのは変わって変わっていくもんなんですね
そうやっていい加減でね
いいか悪いかわからないものっていうのは
守るということもあんまり
まあいい加減な人は守りますけどね
みんなやれというんだからやると
みんな酒飲んでるんだから飲むんだ
それが正しいやと みんな麻薬使ってるんだから使ってるんだ
だってみんなやってるんではないか
そんな感じでみんな生きてるんですね
だからこの 現代 世界というかね
ていうかまあ人間はみんな現代というところじゃなくて
昔から別に自分でわかって何かやってるわけじゃなくてね
まあ誰かがそう言うんだったら
大勢の人が言うとやる
あるいは誰か凶暴な強い人が何か言うんだったら
まあそれが正しいとやる
まあどちらかなんですね
あるいは自分の都合によって
まあ善悪判断決めちゃうという
ですから まあね 世の中でいう善悪判断に
に合わせて 守って生活したっても
そんなにしっかりした立派な人格が生まれてくるとは
私はないと思いますね
それで物事判断というのは
法律の判断と同じくしっかりした方がいいんです
でも それは難しい じゃあ法律の判断のようにと私は言ったんだから
じゃあ法律はどうでしょうかと
なんか一見しっかりしているようには見えます
例えば殺人だ 殺人犯だったら
まあ殺人犯として認めるためには
どういう条件必要かというね
は決まってるんです  まあそうですね
法律の研究家がいるんだから
私が言ったら間違いかもしれませんだけど
間違ったら直してください
[笑い]一応ね まあ殺意がある必要はね
まず で それでまあ 自分の
の手段で死ぬ必要があるんですね
だから私が殴った人がね
車にはねられて死んじゃっても
私が殺 殺人になりません
殺意って何と言いますかね
何か 言いますね  故意  え？ 故意
うん 法律的にはなんか
え 故意  故意？うん  そういう人が死ななくちゃいけないんですね
そういうものはできるだけこの間接的に証拠ではなくて
あの直接的なディレクトエビデンスというものが必要なんですね
何でしたっけ？それは
それは直接証拠  直接証拠あった方がしっかりする
じゃあそれは全部揃ったらもう殺人でやることはね
で このディレクトエビデンス
直接証拠の中で一番大事
遺体が見つからなかったら
もういくら証拠揃ってもあの
証明することはできません
ですから 法律的にあの
あの 何丸 えひめ丸 あの船で沈んだあの人々は未だに行方不明者なんです
遺体が見つからない限りは
死者とは法律的には認めません
行方不明者  そういうふうな
まあはっきりしているんですね
だからそこら辺揃ったら
まあ大丈夫ということで
まあ間接的な証拠でも大丈夫ですけど
なかなか難しいですね
間接的な証拠が全く疑いの余地なく
この人だっていうことはものすごい明確に証明しないとね
そういうことで でも 日本だったらまあ十年振りまああっちこっち隠れていれば
まあそれでも訴追にならないとかもあるし
で 他の国々はまた別々にあるでしょうし
アメリカだったら殺人は年で逃げるわけじゃないんです
もうとにかくもう時効っていうのはない
まあ捕まるという だから法律にしてもしっかりしているんですが
まあそれまた国によってまた変わる
それで言いたかったのは
この最近なんか子供が殺したんだっていうね
裁判があって 無罪になっちゃったんですね
無罪っていうことに だから他の誰が殺したかっていうことはわからないし
女の人を捕まえていたんですけどね
だからあの女の人が何のことなく
まあ無罪ですから もうまた訴えることもできない
誘拐で訴えることもできないし
なぜならばなんか電話で呼び寄せたみたいんですね
なんかこう まあ傷害 殺意で訴えることもできない
殺した証拠ないんだけど
傷害を与えて なぜならば傷害はもうとっくに時効なんです
だから残ったのは  たった殺人罪だけでしたけど
まあ証拠はない 全部間接的にこの人しかないという
この人ということで この女の人はもう徹底的に黙秘権という使っていたんです
そんなところが全部お世話になりました
ですから 結局子供が殺されちゃったんですけど
じゃあその犯罪者を裁けますかというと
裁けないんですね ですから
しっかりした法律の中でも堂々と住みおかして
まあ逃げることもできます
ですから 法律さえもしっかりしていないということなんですね
言いたいのは で 法律しっかりしてない
だからまあずっと変えなくちゃあかんもんなんですね
改良していかなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば 犯罪が大きくなってくると
もうちょっと法律を厳しくしなくちゃいけないし
子供まで子供でも二歳の子供でも人殺ししたりすると
人殺しいいの大丈夫大丈夫と言って税金を払ってよりいい教育をさせてあげるとか
それはちょっともうおかしい話でしょうしね
ですからまあ 法律変えなくちゃいけないということになっちゃいますね
ですから この善悪判断に戻りますけど
善悪判断っていうのは
やっぱり世の中でそうやって曖昧
科学的に物事を考えなくちゃいけないという法律にしたってもしっかりしたシステムを作るということは難しいということは
人間作ることだから この判断能力はもともと人間にはそんなにないんですね
ですから 曖昧なところになるんです
で 宗教の場合でもその弱さが見えるんですね
善悪判断ができなくて困ったというところはね
一般的には宗教の世界で悪いことをしてはいけないと
いいことをするべきですよという考え方はあります
どんな宗教でも あるんだけど
問題は悪いことって何？いいことって何？と聞いたところでわからないんですね
それで一般的な このあまり知識にも知恵にも基づいてない宗教の場合は
この脅しでいくんですね
で その時にあった何か勝手な何か何かリストを作って
神がこういう風に決めましたと
だから自分でこれを悪いと理解しなくてもしても
これあんた関係ない 神が決めたリストを守れと
神が決めたと言ったっても
それはそこら辺の誰かがね
まあ善悪決めることですけど
で 神が決めたんだからまず改良できない
そうすると人間というのはどうしますかというと
このリストを見て 法律と同じくそれを守るんだけど
リストにない悪いことは平気でやる
だからしっかりしないんですね
結局は それでその場合はもう神に恐れてやってるだけだからね
自分の人格が直すために
この自分で判断する 自分で決める
自分の心の中から罪を嫌うという
あの精神的な育ちが出てこないんですね
ですから まあそこら辺でそういうの危険です
そういうまあ 大概知らない
何かに依存して形而上的で論理的じゃない善悪観なんですね
世の中にあるのは 脅しでやりますね
神の怒りを買ってしまっちゃうとかね
天国に行けないとかね
それでははっきりときちんとこの
善悪を決めようではないかということは
仏教はその問題にチャレンジしたんです
だからもう膨大にそこら辺触れなくちゃいけないんですけどね
まあ興味のないだろうと思いますけどね
真剣に考えちゃうと 本当に生きることがいい加減になっているのは
善悪判断をしっかりしないことで
それをきちんと科学的に論理的に設定しておくと
かなり守りやすいものにもなるし
お釈迦様はそのチャレンジにしっかりと答えましたけど
他の宗教も頑張ったような気はしますけど
インドの他の宗教でもね
でもあんまりこの論理的に設定してないんです
やっぱりどこかで経済学的なところから始まっちゃうっていうことが出てくるんですね
ジャイナ教では 輪廻はかなり論理的に説明してますけど
やっぱりスタートはもう経済学的なところなんですね
まあまあ それでもっていうのは
すごいこの 本当はすごい失敗した倫理学っていうものがあるんです
仏教の基本的なことっていうのは
この人 生命っていうのは
この幸せになりたいっていうことは
幸せになりたいと思っていることは
どんな生命でもことごとく持っているんですね
それはなんかこの生命権利みたいなもので
もう それはまあ変えることはできないんです
誰にも奪うことはできないんですね
人間にはまあ権利があるんです
幸せになりたいという思う権利がね
幸福になりたいと これは動物でも同じなんですね
それがもうついてます
教える必要さえないんです
人権権利とかいうもんとかね
それとは全然違います
誰でも持っている ですから
そこら辺の証拠必要ではありません
一億人中一人ぐらいいたってもね
私は幸せになりたくないんだと
不幸になりたいんだと
そう思う人が 一億人中一人いたとしたっても
それはもう計算に入りませんだからね
一億人の人が幸せになりたいと思っているんだから
その人が思うことだけ真理ですと言えないでしょうに
逆に幸せになりたくない人はご飯食べる必要ないんですからね
ご飯食べる必要ないし
仕事する必要ないし 勉強する必要ないし
努力する必要がないんでしょうに
そのまま死ねばいいでしょうに
ですから 幸せになったくないと思う人は生きてないっていうことはまあ成り立たぬんです
生きてるんだったらもう幸せになりたいという本能が透けてるんだっていうことなんです
そういうことで お釈迦様が
もう生命が切望している幸福を妨げるものが悪であって
それが克服できる道が善の道であるという
だから幸福になる道が善の道で
不幸になる道が不善の道で悪の道なんですね
ある時はまあ 何でしたっけ
スカセタンアディワチャナンガリダンプンヤンというお釈迦様の言葉がありまして
あのスカー 幸福の 善行
プンヤっていうのは功徳というんですけど
功徳というのは幸福の土俵ですよと
だからトクオソム 幸福になる
という意味なんですね
だからお釈迦様の道徳観というかね
善悪判断というのは しっかりと幸せになる道
それは善の道 不幸になる道
それは不善の道 それが嫌と言った人がアホしか言えないんですよ
私はそんないろいろ言ってる
いいことやりたくないんだとかね
楽に行きたいんだとか言ったらもうアホなんです
なぜかというと きちんと計算してお釈迦様が楽な幸せに行く道が善の道だと言っているんだから
そこで幸せになるために
これがこれがこれが必要ですよと
こういうことをすれば不幸になりますよという風に
その上でリストが成り立っているのです
ですから お釈迦様 仏教にある道徳なんかは守るか守らないかではなくて
それはもういい加減 お釈迦様が独裁
独裁的に独善的に言っているものは
お釈迦様がおっしゃったんだから
我々はもう何て言いますか
無批判的で伝統的で守っているのかと
だから現代我々はそれを改良するべきだとかね
もうちょっと考え直した方がいいんじゃないかとかね
そのややこしい もう戒律などとかね
そういう考え方があるんですけど
そういう人々も お釈迦様も初めから言ったね
まあアホで無知というね
ことしかね まあ愚か者という仏教の簡単にそういう言葉を使ってますからね
すごい単純なことで だって幸福になりたい
自由に不幸になることしませんと言ったら愚か者でしょうね
長生きしたい だから毒を飲みますと言ったら
まあ愚か者でしょうね
ですから まあそういうことを使ってますけどね
そこで まあブッダがお釈迦様が教えた一つ一つ項目を見て
じゃあこれを守ったら私は不幸になるかと調べたら簡単にわかります
例えば嘘をつくなよと言ってますね
嘘をつくなと言ったところで不幸になるんだと
うまくいかないんだと
うまくいかないかと調べてみれば
嘘言っていいでしょうかと
だから誰も研究しないで言うだけで
この世の中で嘘をつかなくちゃ生きていられないんだとか
それ怠け者のことであって
怠けというわけじゃないでしょうに
嘘も方便だよというのは
これはもうする人の言い方であって
ズルさっていうのはいいわけじゃないでしょうに
じゃあそれで完全な安全な生き方でしょうかと
完全な安全になるかと
そうじゃないでしょうに
この中で嘘をついてどれほど人が不幸になっているかというとね
キリがないでしょうに
そういうふうに考えてみれば
やっぱり一つ一つの項目は幸福になるために設定しているということはわかると思います
それでこの項目はね 道徳の項目
もうとっくに判断しているんです
私たちに別に判断 私たちがしなくていいんです
お釈迦様が一度判断してリストがいてるんですけどね
だから我々にとっては判断能力はないんですね
そこら辺お釈迦様判断してくれる
我々に持っているのは幸せになりたいという希望というかね
その本能的な衝動だけなんですね
でもどうすればなれるかっていうことはわからない
で 智慧がないんですね
それで智慧の完成したんだから
お釈迦様がお釈迦様が教えている
お釈迦様が自分が最高の幸福に達しましたと
達しましたと だから最高の幸福に達しましたから
その最高の幸福への道っていうふうなことで
方法っていうのを教えるんですね
一般的な人々思っている幸せ
幸福も否定しているわけじゃなくてね
まあ一般的にでもね 家庭がうまくいって
収入があって 健康的で
社会とは問題起こらないで明るく生きるということも同じことで
そんなアホにできるわけじゃないし
怒ったり嘘をついたり
人を騙したり もうね 賄賂を取ったりする人にはそんなことできるわけないでしょうに
邪悪な行為をしたり 好き勝手に生きていて
勝手に守るということができるわけじゃないでしょう
ですから お釈迦様の道っていうのは
世俗的な幸福も まあとても簡単に満たすことができるし
それより精神的な幸福まで体験できるものなんです
そこはまあ議論で それからこの仏教にもね
一般 一般向けの仏教と
まあ仏教のお坊さんたちに我々勉強する苦労の世界っていうのはまたあるんです
で それになってくると
そんな簡単にね 善悪はそれぐらいやということで終わらないんです
結構厳しく激しく勉強しなくちゃいけないことになるんです
それでこの 厳密に仏教を解説してね
全く間違えないように
お釈迦様が思ったその意思通りに理解するために
ということで この いろいろ工夫があります
これかなり難しいんですけどね
勉強するのは そのレベルは
で 今ほとんどそれ そこまでやってる人がいないぐらいなんですけど
そちらでこの善と悪 クサラとアクサラですね
アクサラっていうのは悪
まあクサラっていうのは善
で だから善と悪というのは善と不善なんですね
それでこの徹底的に絶対的な不善って何なのか
それはまあ九つあるんです
絶対的な不善 他の悪行為はその不善から生まれるもんなんです
九つ その九つあるならば
もういっそ悪行為をするか分からないんですね
いっそ不善的なことをするかという
罪を犯すということはもうわからない
だからきちんと善悪をつかむということもできなくなるんです
ではリストで説明します
一番目はタンハなんですね
タンハっていうのは渇愛と一般的に日本語で言うんです
で このタンハっていうものは
もう もうこれは大変なきつい
この あの キリスト教で言ってる原罪みたいなもんなんです
どうにもならんですよ
タンハっていうのは渇愛だから
この なんかこの衝動が生まれちゃうんですね
例えばものを見たらきれいと思うのは
まあ別に自然的なことなんですね
ご飯食べたら美味しいと思うということは
もう全く自然行為なんですよ
それは不善でも何でもないんです
例えば まあ人間はほとんど動物も同じですけど
甘いものが好き これ嫌いになれていったってね
どうにもならん 体はあのエネルギーとして砂糖必要だから
もう動物でも甘いもの好きなもうコバさんみたいにね
もう結構好きなんですね
美味しいでしょうね だから
人間の小さい時からもう何のことなく甘いものだったらもう食べちゃうっていうことあるんですね
苦いものは嫌嫌 嫌になっちゃうんですね
ですから もうそうやって口に入ったものをおいしいと思うのはもうどうにもならんことで
善悪とは関係ないんです
何かきれい 何か見たらきれいだと思っちゃうことも
もう善悪と関係ないんですね
でもそこで渇愛が生まれるわけです
きれいなものは欲しいと
衝動が生まれるんですね
何か食べておいしいと思ったら
もうさらに食べたいという衝動が生まれてくる
それから探しちゃうとかね
あまりにもおいしいと思っちゃうと
あまりにも欲しいと思っちゃうと
もう もう手段も選ばず
それをもう獲得しようとします
ですから ものすごい大きな隅まで我々はこの操られるのはこの渇愛なんですね
それでこの欲しいものには渇愛が生まれるんだけど
じゃあ嫌なものには何でしょうかとかね
そうすると あの ネガティブ方向へ渇愛が生まれちゃうんですね
何か嫌なもの目に入っちゃうと
ああ見たくないという
とにかくそこから逃げようという
あるいはそのものを壊そうという衝動が生まれちゃうんですね
ですから そういうどうにもならんところで
我々には渇愛というものが心に生まれるんです
そこはもう一番の悪 あの衝動は
渇愛っていうもの だから花を見て綺麗に感じることはそれでも何でもないんです
ああ綺麗と感じるともう渇愛が生まれているんです
なんと綺麗ですかと思っちゃうと
もう渇愛が生まれているんです
もうそういうことですから
渇愛っていうのは一切の生命にあるんですね
それ取り除けますよ だからこれは
あの でもすごい難しいんですね
二番目はアヴィッジャというんですね
このアヴィッジャということのようですね
それもどうにもならん
すべての生命にある原罪みたいなもんなんです
これはどういうことかというと
この現象しかもう世の中で何も存在しないんです
この個体は存在しない
我々個体と言っているのは現象
一時的なもの だからスクリーンに映るあの映像みたいなもんで
そちらに映像あるわけじゃないんです
なんとかからくりでそこで映像見える
あの三次元の映画とかあります
それで映画館に行ったら眼鏡かける
眼鏡かけたら もう人間やら場面やら全部生きてくるんですね
目の前でみんな踊ったり遊んだりする
だから向こう側から歌ってる人がこうやって手を出すと
自分の目のところから向こうへ手が来るんですね
だからかなりもうリアルで感じるんですね
でもあれはあれ からくりなんですよ
眼鏡だからそう見えるんであって
眼鏡外したら何のことなく
あの ボケてる映像がスクリーンに映ってるだけ
全くもう面白く何もない
生々しく映っていますから
もうかなりボケてます
それで眼鏡かけた途端
なんのことか サメなんかこうやって自分の目の前でもう動いていくとかね
だから映画館に行ってみたら
時々花が落ちるとかありますけど
みんなこうやって手を出して捕まったり
捕まえようと見せたりするんです
映画の  あっちこっちありますから
大阪にもあるし ディズニーランドに行けばそちらもあるし
新宿にもそういう映画館があるし
まあいろんなところにいろいろところにありますけど
だからリアルに見える
でもそのリアルに見える世界はリアルにあるわけじゃないんですね
現象なんです 眼鏡外しちゃえば終わり
見えません あるいはあの
撮影する時のあの特別な技術使わなかったら
それまた見えません それであのアヴィッジャ
無明っていうのは この世の中がそうやってリアルにあると思ってることが無明なんです
全ては瞬間しか存在しない
次の瞬間で別なものなんですね
だから一時的な瞬間的な現象のみ
我々美味しいと思うものも
嫌だ嫌だ思うものも 一つもリアルなものではありません
あれは三次元の映像みたいに
もう我々の頭の中で生まれる錯覚だけなんですね
それがどうしようもないでしょうに
私たちにとっては 無常っていうのは見えません
私たちは店に 店に行って
あのリンゴを買う 同じリンゴを家に持ってきたと思ってるんです
で 買ったリンゴが家に持ってきたら違うものになるんだぞと思ったら買えなくなっちゃうんです
でも違うものになってるんです
ずっと止まることなくリンゴは変化しているんだから
もう変わってるんですけど
買った人は家にリンゴを持ってくることもできない
その人も同じスピードで変化しているんだから
だから結局は買った人
リンゴと買った人が別なんですね
別な人が別なリンゴを買って
別な人が別なリンゴを家に置いておくんですけど
それは全然わからないんです
毎日同じ人に会うことは全くないんです
だからそこは発見できないんだから
そこは無明と言うんですね
それを取り除くのは大変難しい
かなり鋭い智慧っていうのは
瞬間で全て見られるという智慧っていうのは
いわゆるこの あの幻想化する機能を一つずつ見ない限りは
まあ無常であることは見えませんね
我々は意外と遅い 瞬時に聞けないんです
聞いたものを頭の中でいろいろ
何て言いますか チャネルを回して
ああ 聞きましたと言うんだから
結構遅いんですね あれでもう幻想を作って終わってるんです
幻想だけじゃなくて 感情も作って
怒りも欲も作って 見た
見た聞いたとするんです
だからこの もう 電気より速さで瞬時にするっていう機能を育ててみれば
無明っていうのは飛び出します
なくなります それでそれがあるんだから
私たちは他の罪もいっぱい起こしちゃうんですよ
人が見たら なんて綺麗な人ですかと思っちゃうと
あ この人と一緒になりたい
なれっこはないんだけどね
それでその人には別な好きな人がいると
どうぞその人のことを憎しみだけする
あんないろんなことができちゃうんですね
そう なれっこはないし
一緒になろうと思ったってもね
別だから また すぐ変わりますから
あちらもこちらも 綺麗だと思ったことも頭の中の幻覚幻想でしょうしね
だからこの無明というものがある限りは
我々はどんな罪を犯すか分かったもんじゃないんです
だから一番この究極的な罪
この二つは あの 殺害と無明
次にあるのは三つ 貪欲
貪瞋痴 みんな知ってる三毒ですね
そうすると一寸になります
貪瞋痴はこの渇愛と無明から出てくる
まあ少々弱い 少々弱いだけで
私たちにとっては基本的な衝動ですけどもね
貪りっていうのは 好き好きっていうことは
怒りっていうのは嫌々ということで
無知っていうのは面白くないってことなんです
だから いつでもその三毒で生きているんです
何か 何か見たら すげえ綺麗というね
そうすると貪り 貪 老婆が生まれてくる
ああ 嫌なものよって思ったら
もう怒りが生まれてくる
なんだと思っちゃら無知なんです
だからこの我々毎日見たり聞いたり感じたり
味わったり 喋ったりするものすべて
そのいつでもその貪瞋痴を作ってるんですね
だからこのよく覚えておくのは
貪りの情報か怒りの情報ですね
無知したものは覚えてないんですね
無知するものは ですから
それはだから無知と言うんですよ
なぜならば 人が怒りと欲と生きていても
何か知ってるんですよ
世の中のこれこれ綺麗なものがある
これこれ嫌な奴らがいるとかね
知っていて それでひどい目に遭ったりして
何か人生経験あるんですね
そうすると あなたもういい加減にしなさいと
あなたこういうものを
好きなものを追っていて
すごいひどい目に遭ったでしょうと
嫌なものを壊そう壊そうとして
ひどい目に遭ったでしょうと
それは経験を持ってるんだから
あ そうですか じゃあなんか頑張りますということには可能性はあるんだけど
なんだかんだ無知する人にとっては
それだけ上げる見方がなくなっちゃうんですね
無知があると 貪瞋痴の血が入っちゃうと
だって面白くないんだから
その人に別に だから自分危険な目に遭った経験さえもないんですね
だから人生面白くないとかね
何もやりたくないとかね
そうやって落ち込む傾向に行ってしまっちゃうんですね
どうにもならん これ無知の塊
だから貪り怒りより無知の方が強烈になると
みんなダメになっちゃうんですね
怒りと欲 老婆とベースがある人々は頑張っちゃいますけどね
戦争しようではないかとかね
この道になってやろうではないかとかね
そういう風に頑張るんですけど
それがないんですね 無知中心の人には
時々 あのこの子は本当に欲が少なくってとか
そんないい加減なことをアホな人に言ってはいけないんですよ
欲が少ないかも 生まれつき無知かどうかわかりませんからね
ですから この基本的な貪欲とも言っているし
皆様がよく説法で聞いてるその三毒なんです
それは一般的にわかりやすいものですからね
貪瞋痴っていうのは それで一寸ですね
次にこのサンニャー 四つあります
サンニャーっていうのはね
思考みたいなもんで 考え方のようなもので
五蘊の中にサンニャーあるでしょ
受想行識っていうのは想っていうのがありますね
三番目 だからサンニャーっていうのは我々の知識やと思ったってね
頭で考えてる量が全部サンニャーやと
そこらへんで 四つのサンニャーがあるんで
一番目はスダサンニャー
スダサンニャーっていうのは
物事は良いもので 価値があるものやと
いいものやと思うこと
これサンニャーだから自分の思考なんですね
あれがいい これもいいんでしょうというふうに
この いい 良い側面しか見えない性格
それだったらもう決して悟りっていうことは
解脱っていうことは成り立たないんですね
で スダという風に スダっていうのはなかなか日本語には訳できないものなんですけど
まあ浄清らかっていう感じはね
伝統的に日本語仏教ではつけてますけどね
まあそれでみんなわかるわけでもないんですけど
まあ浄でもよろしいですけどね
清らかっていう感じ なのでそこらへんは私が無価値というところに
その思考を作るために一つの根拠として
このこれを証拠になるんです
これだけじゃない 無価値論はもっと広く考えていったもので
あの というふうに それに支えのある専門的な仏教概念というのはまたいくつかあるんです
学問的に向き合い方を設定しようと思えば
かなり膨大な研究論文を書かないと難しいんです
とにかくスササンニャ
スササンニャっていうのは
ああ綺麗 ああ綺麗と 綺麗というか清らか
価値があると 例えば川の河岸がなんて綺麗ですかと
でも死体の川でしょうね
あれは なぜ死体の川だと思わないんですかね
人を見たらなんて綺麗なのよと
もうただ歩いてる死体なんですけど
臭いんですけど それは見えないんですね
人を見たらなんて綺麗なのよと
もうただ歩いてる死体なんですけど
臭いんですけど それは見えないんですね
だからスササンニャで生きていると
まあ罪を犯しちゃうし
それ一つの仏教で罪なんです
次にスカサンニャ スカっていうのは幸福
楽という 自分の今の状況はこれがあれば幸せ
これがあれば幸せ これがあれば幸せ
そうやっていろんなものを頭の中で
このスカっていうこと
現象について 幸せ 幸せだと思っちゃうことも罪なんですよ
結局は 一般説法では言えないんだから控えておくんです
お金だったらなんて幸せかなと思ったら
もうとっくに罪を犯してるんです
こんな環境のいいところで自分も家を建てればいいなと
なんて幸せかなとかね
もうそれも罪なんです
これはスカサンニャ で
次にあるのはニッチャ
ニッチャサンニャという
この あの これは あの 永遠不滅なものがあるんだって思うことなんですね
あの 常住しているものがあるんだと
変わらぬものがあるんだと
何か変わらないものがとにかくあるんでしょうと思って探すんですね
だから宗教はそこら辺で生まれたでしょ
どんな宗教でも変わらない
永遠 死なない 永遠 不死なる永遠の解放を語ってるんですよ
だからこの専門的なレベルから仏教
専門的な仏教から見れば
みんな罪を犯してるんです
禅だと思って有禅語ってるんです
永遠の天国 極楽道 永遠
という何か約束しちゃうんですね
永遠なもの だから彼らが禅を語るその理ですけど
結局は有禅語ってるんです
で あれが無明だからあるんだと
変わら変わらないものがあるんだと
そう勘違いするだけ 例えば店で買ったリンゴは変わるわけないんでしょ
家に持ってきたっていうのは
家に持って週間置いていたってもと思ってるでしょうね
あれは見えないからそう思っちゃうんであって
瞬間で見える人だったら
もうこれはもう変わっているんだっていうことはもう
見えるんです 私たちにはリンゴがもう変わったんだとわかるためには
もう 一ヶ月 あの こうやって指で叩いたら
まああの なんか音がボーンボーンってもうダメだと
そういうものもそうです
でもあれも突然それ変わったわけじゃないでしょうに
弁当でも食べ物でもちゃんと賞味期限書いてますから
その賞味期限までいて
それから突然悪くなるっていうことないでしょうに
ゆっくりと変わっていくんだから
ゆっくりではないんだけどね
ずーっと変わっていくんですけど
だから ものはだからものはあるんだっていうことが出てきて
それでまあミッチャサンニャ
私にはもう何か永遠不滅なものがあるんだよと思っちゃうんですね
で そこも大縁の隅の一つで
最後にアッタサンニャ
アッタサンニャっていうのは魂があるんだっていうこと
ミッチャサンニャっていうのは
物事は自分に魂だけではなくて
物事はもうずっとあるんだぞという考え方ですね
アッタっていうのは この魂があるんだと
変わらないのかという
そういう思考大体みんなにあるんですね
みんなに渇愛というものがあるんだから
物事は消えようと見るし
貪瞋痴もあるし それから物事からね
幸せが得られると思っているし
それから物事はもうずっとあるんだと勘違いするし
で それが最後に自分には我もあるんだと
魂もあるんだと思ってる
そこから私にはそんな考え方ないよという人はいません
原罪みたいなものなんです
渇愛というものはあるんだから
だから渇愛離離と初めてのはそういうわけなんです
渇愛理解すれば これはどうにもならん
もう必ずあるんだということがわかるんです
それで修行する御尊たちがもう身を張らないで謙虚で
いくら出家したっても
自分が世の中素早く清らかなものだと思っているアホやと
それよく知った上で修行するんですね
逆の方向へ見えるまではね
お釈迦様の教えを信じているんだから
私は魂なんかあると思ってないんだよと言ったって
魂があると思っているんです
どうにもならん 私が言う我があるともう思ってるんです
いくら仏教の話聞いても
なぜわかったらもう悟ってます
それで もうよりかに悟ってるんです
我はない それだけは事実だとわかったらね
まあそれからこの まあそこココナッツヴィパッサナー
タンマー アヴィッダ ローブ
ドーサ モーハ それからスブサンニャ
スブサンニャ スカサンニャ
ニッチャサンニャ アッタサンニャ
ココナッツ これは原罪
それが罪なんです それが不善なんです
それがあると心になるんです
でも そういうのあるんです
だから輪廻に輪廻が幸福になるっていうことはなり方ないんです
ただそれ錯覚だけ 家があって幸せや
家族がいて幸せやとかね
お金があって幸せ そんなのは錯覚
それからもう禅のココナッツ
1番目はサマタ サマタっていうのはまあサマタ瞑想でしょ
で 何か対象を取って心を集中する方法
サマタ瞑想ですね そうすると心はあっちこっち混乱しないで集中できるんだから見られるんです
集中するためには他の対象からね
心を離れてもらって 静かなところで体も動かさないで
きちんと一つだけ対象をじーっと観察して観察して
ずっと観察していくと
妄想のプロセスが消えちゃうんです
消えて それだけじっと見られるようになるんです
そこでサマーディというんです
だから何か見ていると
これが花だ これは綺麗だという感じで見てると
もう妄想回転しているんだから
間が間にこの邪魔者が入ってるんですね
ですから サマーディが生まれてこない
ですから花が見たら花見たりとか
この花は左に寄って立った方が綺麗とか言うでしょうに
サマーディの世界じゃないんですよ
もういろんな妄想だらけで見てるんだからね
そういう思考何も無い
ただ見えるだけ それがサマーディなんです
サマーディ作るためにはサマタが必要なんですね
だからサマタは善巧の一番目
善の一部 で心がけるんですよ
二番目は当然なことでヴィパッサナー
で 初期仏教 原始仏教ではサマタ
ヴィパッサナーっていうのはいつでもセットで離れません
うーん ヴィパッサナーのみっていう話じゃないんです
サマタやって それからヴィパッサナーやるっていうこともあるし
ヴィパッサナーずっとやって
いくらか行ったところで
まあささっとサマタやるっていう方法もありますけど
でないと両方まとめていっぺんにやらなくてはいけないですね
サマタ ヴィパッサナー
サマタ ヴィパッサナーで渇愛は
サマタで渇愛は大体控えます
控えるだけ で ヴィパッサナーで渇愛というものがとけます
次の善巧は あの 不貪・不瞋・不痴というね
貪瞋痴の三つの反対のこと
それで貪瞋痴の説明で私はこの痴を優先な人っていうのはどうにもならん
もうもう落ち込みでもう役にも立たないだらしない人間になるんだと説明したでしょう
だからすべて無視するんだからね
助けてあげることさえもできないんだから
むしろくまーいとか言ったらどうにもならんでしょうに
話聞きたくないと言ったら
今の若者みたいに聞きたくない
行きたくないと もうそのままもう胸ぐら縫い出しちゃえばいいんです
役に立ちません 逆にあの不貪・不瞋・不痴の場合は
痴 それだけ見ているんだという場合はね
すごい智慧が生まれてくるんです
すごいあの 覚醒的になります
だからこの とにかく不貪・不瞋・不痴という三つ
それで全部のそれから逆になります
アスリサンニャ この思考の場合は物事を浄ではなくて不浄で見なさいと
ということで いわゆる無価値なものであって
ゴミで見るんですね 人が綺麗と思ったって瞬間だけのことで
自分もその人も変わっちゃうでしょうし
綺麗綺麗でいたっての
ただ何があるかというと
皮膚があって筋肉があって骨があって
血液があって いろいろ汚れがいっぱいあってとかね
もう見ただけで 見たらすごい怖くなってくる
例えばすごい美女見て
なんて綺麗だ 体を剥いてみてください
何て言うかと思いますかね
その時は 怖くて眠れるでしょうに
だからこのいろいろホラー映画なんかでは
ほんのちょっと目がちょっとおかしくして見せる
あるいは口なんかちょっとおかしくして見せる
それだけのことでみんなものすごい怖くなって
気持ち悪いと言うでしょうに
だからちょっと変わったらそんなもんでね
あれ別に変わるわけじゃなくて
いろいろメイクアップするだけでね
実際に変わったらどうでしょうかと
ですから この不浄で見なさいと
そこをだから不浄で見ることが禅なんです
それからスッカ・サンニャーの反対
幸せだ 幸福だと見るんではなくて
現象はドゥッカだよと見る
苦だよと見る 次に 永遠には変わらないんだではなくて
無常だと見る アニッチア・サンニャー
だからドゥッカ・サンニャー
アニッチア・サンニャー
最後に実体はない 無我であると見る
その知 見方 知識 それがもう究極的な禅
これより優れたものはないんです
だから禅と仏教の究極的なところはこちらなんです
他のはもう一般的にね
殺すなよとかね 嘘つくなよとかね
そういうのはもう非常に一般的なことで
この ここの知ってる人にとってはもう関係ない
もう何も罪を犯しません
で  お釈迦様の教えによるとね
まあ禅というのはね ここます
成り立ってますからね
まあその中でサマタとヴィパッサナーっていうのは二つは対照的に出てきて
それは修行方法で心を統一すること
これがもう大変な禅行為なんですね
サマタ瞑想っていうのは
世の中で悪いことをする人は
誰でも心を統一しているんだから悪いことをしてるんではなくて
心を混乱しているんだから悪いことをしているんですね
人を殺したりするときでも
必ず人の心が混乱しているんですね
で 落ち着いて 穏やかな気持ちで
リラックスした気持ちで人を殺したりすることはできません
よこしまな行為をするときでも
そういう穏やかな気持ちで清々しい気持ちでできるってわけじゃないんです
嘘を言うときは そういう分元気で気持ちよくできますかね
できないんですよ だから一切の罪っていうのは
心が混乱した状態で生まれてくるものなんですね
だから悪いことをする人っていうのは
必ず心混乱しているってことがあるんです
ですから 悪いことそのものよりも
心が混乱していることが一番悪い
それが罪なんですね ですから
サマタをすること 心を統一すること
心を落ち着いてもらうこと
これが禅の泉になって
その人は悪行為を全くしないっていうことになるんですね
すぐに人間がなぜ悪いことをするかというと
やっぱりこの無知だからなんですね
私がいるんだ 他人がいるんだという
その無知の基本的なところから
すべての悪いことをしてしまっちゃうんですね
次に やっぱり心 安定しただけでは足らない
安定しただけで無知はそのままだから
心混乱する可能性あります
安定した心でいても 他人から何か言われると心がまた混乱している可能性あります
ですから 他人から何か言われても
それはちゃんと理解して
こういうことやと こちらっていうことを理解できる人は混乱しない
ですから それはできるのは智慧がある人だけなんですね
ですから このヴィパッサナーっていうのは二番目の禅になっているんですね
このリストの中 で 次のリストに出てきているのは
サマタ・ヴィパッサナー実践する人が心の汚れを取り除くということだから
貪瞋痴なくしてしまっちゃうとかね
で こんなことになっているんです
ですから この修行やる分というのは大変ありがたいことで
ヴィパッサナー修行する人が生まれて初めて
この 生まれて初めてというか
輪廻の中で初めてと言ったってもいいんですよ
初めて心を清らかにしようとする
洗ってみようとする努力なんですね
ですから これ以上徳というものは
幸福になるものっていうのはないんですね
ですから 修行した分が自分たちには非常に役に立ちましたと
役に立ちますということは覚えておいていただきたいんです
決して無駄にはなりません
それからまあ ヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのはね
まあ普通の瞑想と違っているところが見失いになるなって
これはまああの 生きていることを研究することですからね
だから生きていることを研究する
研究してそれを発見する
ですから どんな 1 秒でもヴィパッサナーをしなくちゃいけないんですね
どんな 1 秒でも生きてるんだからね
だからこの 罪にヴィパッサナーの生き方っていうのは必要なんです
悟るまで 24時間体制でヴィパッサナーっていうのをしなくちゃいけない
24時間体制っていうのはちょっと大げさな言い方で
あの 眠っている間はやっぱり気づくということっていうのは必要なんですね
そうすると 日常生活の中で気づいている人は全く罪を犯さないんです
犯さないんです だから罪を犯さない生き方できるということほどありがたいこと
幸福なことっていうのはありえますかね
ありえないんです だからそういう日常生活の中で
何やってもちょっと気づいておく
客観的に知っておく 私が私がではなくて
怒りが起こっても 私が
怒りが出た 怒りそのものを修行にして怒りが出た
混乱が生まれた 怒ったんだ
怒ったんだと思っちゃうと
なんとなく自分のものでもう持っているんですね
ですから この そういう感じで
この常にこの客観的に生きるということになると
まあたとえ怒った瞬間にヴィパッサナーがない
だから怒っちゃうんです
混乱した瞬間でヴィパッサナーがなく
だから混乱しちゃうんですね
だから煩悩があるんだから
まあこれはもう そういうことはいつでもあり得ることです
だから怒った瞬間はそれはもうしょうがないんだけど
次の瞬間にそれを客観化する
怒りが出たと あるいはもうこれが怒りですと
それは知っておく これが怒りですと知っている瞬間に
前の瞬間で怒って悪いことを
罪を犯しちゃったんだけど
それよりはぼろ-[音量低下]ですね
だからほんの怒っただけで
まだ何も言ってはないし
相手を殴ってもないしまだ
まだ怒っただけなんですけど
それだけで すぐそれを確認したら
それよりはもうものすごいくるべらのない巨大な善行為をしているんですね
だからあれはもう関係なくなっちゃう
まあそういう風に この日常生活の中でヴィパッサナー実践すると
罪のない生き方っていうのは初めてできるんです
他方法ないんですよ お守りなんか作っちゃったってもね
全然罪のない人生っていうのはまあなりたたないんです
禅定 洗礼を受けるとかいろいろ方法ありますけどね
でも罪人は罪人なんです
洗礼を受けると言って
この水の中にも飛び込んでも
死ぬまで水の中にいたっても
罪人は罪人 ですよ 心清らかにならない
そこで心棒が出てきちゃうと
みんな本物を落ち置いておいて心棒で遊ぶ
だからそれをお釈迦様はすごい厳しく戒めているんです
そんなもう もう遊びじゃないんだからね
人生っていうのは で 何か体に付けたんだからといってね
人格が変わるわけじゃないでしょうに
母親は一生懸命心配して叩いているのに
自分の子供の人格 性格直せないし
どれほど苦労しているかというと
この両親たち知っているでしょうね
子供をしっかりさせるために
それでも失敗する 生まれつきいい子はいい子になっちゃうし
もう生まれつき悪い方向にいる人は
いくら親が踏ん張ってももう悪い方向に行っちゃうし
これもうそんな簡単に治るわけじゃないんですよ
それが体に十字架か もう何かぶら下がっちゃうと
あのカバンにお守り付けたところで治ると言ったら
これはまあちょっと笑えないんですね
それぐらいまあおかしいことなんです
ですから お釈迦様っていうのは
この科学的に厳密に心理学的に心理を見て
で 清らかな心を作る方法を
あの性格を直す方法としてこの方法を教えているんです
だからこれ主観と客観の問題でありまして
主観でものを考えること自体間違ってやって
で 決して正しいことないし
間違った見方で世の中見ていると
行動はすべて間違っちゃうし
間違った見方で行動を直したっても
それがまた間違っているし
見方自体 見解が間違っている
それでやっぱり自分が自分で直すんだぞと思ってなんとかするでしょうね
そのすること自体 自分の間違った見解で見てすることだから
結局人格を直そうとする努力さえも間違ってるんです
だからお釈迦様がそういう難しい仕事をやろうとしてるんです
この主観を破りなさいと
主観を消せと それが間違いだと
客観的に見なさいよと
そうすると見えてくるんだぞと
で それで主観が罪を犯してるんだったら
客観になったら罪がないってこと
ないですよっていうことで
それで客観的になることを教えてるんですね
ですから この日常生活の中でヴィパッサナーを実践してみるならば
使用してみるならば 初めて罪のない人間として生きていられます
でも完璧じゃない 罪犯しちゃうんです
すぐと 煩悩あるんだから
犯しちゃいますけど すぐサティ入れちゃいますからね
この小さな罪が 小さいうちに大きなものでもう潰してるんですね
ですから結果出さないんです
怒りが生まれたら怒りの種があるんですよ
元気な種が かなり恐ろしく成長する可能性あります
あるんだけど ここでサティダンマを取れ
怒りが現れた後 見たところで
もう大きなヴィパッサナーの智慧っていうものが入ったんだから
あの種がもう芽が出なくなっちゃうんです
潰されちゃうんです ですから
この そういう生き方で
まあ罪のない人生っていうのは
まあ送ることができます
ですから これヴィパッサナー成功してみると
もう完全に心清らかになる
だからこれはまあヴィパッサナーのことを覚えておく間だけの話で
実践している間だけの話で
実践やめちゃったら また普段の貪瞋痴の世界に戻ってしまいます
ですから 最終的に心清らかにしなくちゃいけないんですよ
でなければ やりきれないんです
ヴィパッサナー知ってる間はいいんだけど
もうやめたらまた心の中で煩悩が出始め
始まりますからね まあそういうところを理解して
ヴィパッサナー修行自体が大変な功徳な時であること
大変なあの苦毒になるということ
人生はそれでもっと大変な幸福になるし
ヴィパッサナーする人
その瞑想する人っていうのは
生まれ変わるともうすごい頭のいい人間で生まれ変わるもんです
で それからその十八種類をね
まあ見てみたら 皆様に一つ発見できると思いますけどね
すべて心の状況なんです
心理学なんです だからこちらではこの十八に分けて
この徹底的に善 悪 これっていうところで
厳密に心の働きを言ってるんです
心理学ここに 問題は心にあると
ですから この心にまあしがみすぎて罪がある
それをまあ心を育てる教育しか直す方法はない
うん  それで仏教のプロ向きの道徳の話はそこら辺で終了します
この十八覚えておけば
もう全く間違いなし もう生きている
生きている方法 他のこの項目っていうのは自分で作っちゃえばいいんです
作れなかったってのは
その十八で気をつけると
もう もう道徳な人間なんです
では 時間になりましたので
どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございます